QUESTION RIGHT HERE IN NO
POSITION TO LECTURE THE PUBLIC
ABOUT ANYTHING.
>> Katie: HE WINS THEY ARE.
SOME MEDIA OUTLETS ARE PANNING
THE PERFORMANCE AS OFFENSIVE AND
OTHERS ARE SAYING NOBODY CARES.
ONE "VANITY FAIR" WRITER ACCUSED
THE COMEDIAN OF REPEATING A
RIGHT WING TALKING POINT.
RICKY GERVAIS', HOWEVER, IS
HITTING RIGHT BACK ON TWITTER,
SAYING, HOW THE [BLEEP] CAN
TEASING HUGE CORPORATIONS AND
THE RICHEST, MOST PRIVILEGED
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD TO BE
CONSIDERED RIGHT WING?
DOES HE HAVE A POINT, GREG?
>> Greg: NUMBER ONE, RICKY
GERVAIS' ISN'T A RIGHT WINGER.
HE IS A STRONG, OUTSPOKEN
LIBERAL.
HE DOESN'T LIKE TRUMP.
THE THING IS, THIS ISN'T ABOUT
RIGHT OR LEFT.
THIS IS ABOUT FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION AND WHAT SHOULD BE
UNITING CONSERVATIVES AND
LIBERALS OF WHATEVER STRIPE IS
THE RIFT THAT IS GOING ON AMONG
LIBERALS BETWEEN FREE EXPRESSION
AND THOSE WHO WANT TO SILENCE
PEOPLE ON CAMPUS AND THAT IS
WHERE BREAKAGE OF BASE IS COMING
FROM.
IF YOU READ HIS TWITTER FEED,
HE'S EXPRESSING HIS OWN PERSONAL
OUTRAGE OVER CANCEL CULTURE AND
HOW PEOPLE ARE CONSTANTLY BEING
ATTACKED FOR THINGS THEY ARE
SAYING AND IT'S VERY HEALTHY
THAT IT COMES FROM HIM, FROM
SOMEBODY ON THE LEFT.
NO LIBERAL IS GOING TO LISTEN TO
BE BECAUSE YOU'RE JUST GOING TO
SAY, FOX NEWS, THAT GUY, HE
TRASHES EVERYBODY.
AND THEY ARE RIGHT.
BUT WHEN HE COMES OUT AND HE IS
UPSET, WRECKAGE OF BASE IS UPSET
BECAUSE HE IS SO CONFIDENT IN
HIS LIBERAL IDEAS THAT THE
REFUSAL TO LISTEN TO OTHER IDEAS
REFUSAL TO LISTEN TO OTHER IDEAI
REFUSAL TO LISTEN TO OTHER IDEAM
REFUSAL TO LISTEN TO OTHER IDEAA
IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
THE REGRESSIVE LEFT, IN, ENRAGES
HIM.
IT'S A SIGN OF WEAKNESS, SO IT'S
A HARD LEFT THAT IS ACTUALLY
DESTROYING LIBERALISM, NOT
TRUMP-ISM OR CONSERVATISM.
THAT IS WHAT IS FUELING HIS FIRE
AND WHY HE IS SO DISGUSTED AND
ANGRY BUT DO NOT MISTAKE THAT
FOR HIM BECOMING A CONSERVATIVE.
HE IS LIBERAL PEER THE ONLY
POLITICS HE IS INTO AND VERY
STRONGLY, IS ANIMAL RIGHTS.
THIS IS A GUY WHO SPENDS A LOT
OF TIME DEALING WITH HUMANE
ISSUES WITH ANIMALS BUT IT'S
REALLY ABOUT THE RIFT BETWEEN
OLD-SCHOOL LIBERALS LIKE JUAN
AND THE SOCIAL JUSTICE CREEP
TRYING TO SILENCE PEOPLE LIKE
JUAN.
>> Juan: I AGREE, I HAVE BEEN
MUZZLED AND TO THAT POINT I
WOULD SAY YES.
BY THE WAY, I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
WHO RICKY GERVAIS' IS.
>> Greg: HOW DARE YOU?
"THE OFFICE."
>> Juan: AROUND HERE HE IS A
STAR BECAUSE OF WHAT HE DID BUT
THE QUESTION IS, ONE, DO YOU
REALLY THINK PEOPLE DIDN'T MAKE
A POLITICAL SPEECH HE SPOKE?
>> THEY DID.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK IT HAD
THAT IMPACT.
FINALLY, HERE IS SOMEONE VOICIN
VOICING, DISDAIN FOR WHAT THESE
RICH PEOPLE WANT TO TELL US.
>> Sandra: BUT THE HOLLYWOOD
ELITES ARE CRITICIZING HIM FOR
RIGHT WING TALKING POINTS AND HE
SAID, WHAT ABOUT GOING AFTER
LARGE CORPORATIONS AND THE
WEALTHY HOLLYWOOD ACTORS --
>> Juan: I AGREE.
THAT IS THE POINT OF WHAT HE
DID, TO SAY THIS IS A LEGITIMATE
SPEECH AND IT'S FREE SPEECH
COMING FROM THE LEFT, HATS OFF.
BUT TO THE CONTRARY, THE SUPPORT
FOR HIM IS COMING TO THE RIGHT,
WHICH SEES HIM AS OUT THERE ON
THE LEFT.
>> Lawrence: LISTENING TO THE
DAVE CHAPELLES OF THE WORLD,
THIS IS ABOUT THE MOB.
PEOPLE ARE SO SICK AND TIRED OF
EVERYTHING IN THEIR LIFE BEING
CONTROLLED BY THE PAST -- I HAVE
FRIENDS OF MINE, A MAJORITY OF
MY FRIENDS ARE LIBERAL.
THEY TELL ME THEY CAN'T SHARE A
POST THEY MAY AGREE WITH FROM
FOX NEWS BECAUSE THEY WILL GET
FIRED OR THEY WON'T BE INVITED
TO THE NEXT GET TOGETHER OR
SOMETHING BECAUSE THAT IS HOW
THE MOB WORKS.
THIS IS A GUY WHO WAS A LIBERAL
THE JUST WANTS FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION.
>> Sandra: HE'S FREAKING OUT
AT THE MOB BUT ALSO THE FACT
THAT WHAT HE SAID WAS TRUE.
CALLING THEM OUT ON BEHAVIOR
THAT THEY LECTURE THE REST OF
AMERICA ABOUT NOT DOING WHILE
THEY ENGAGE IN IT.
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO DO WHATEVER
THEY WANT WHILE THE PEOPLE THEY
THINK ARE NOT GOOD ENOUGH OR NOT
RICH ENOUGH OR AREN'T IN THE
HOLLYWOOD, LIBERAL CIRCLES, THEY
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE,
BUT THEY HAVE TO BE QUELLED AND
DO WHAT THEY THINK IS RIGHT TO
DO, WITH CLIMATE CHANGE,
HEALTH CARE, OR ANYTHING ELSE
LIKE THAT IN BREAKAGE OF
RICKY GERVAIS' IS A LIBERAL.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMPLAINING ABOUT LOCAL
LEFTISTS.